on that right now i don't want to get
ahead of the line but i want to
rejoining the paris accords is one step
in president joe biden's strategy to
fight global warming
biden plans to spend 1.7 trillion
on rapidly deploying clean energy
technology around the country with an
enforcement mechanism to reach
first stage goals by 2025 and
the final goal of zero emissions by
2050.
biden says he'll pay for that by
repealing some of the trump era tax cuts
for corporations
scientists say biden must also work hard
to dispel
climate change skepticism and convince
people to act
the basic answers to the problem are not
in technological change
they're in changing human behavior biden
should do everything possible
working with social psychologists in
order to develop
narratives that will move people
in the direction of greater social
responsibility and
greater understanding of the existential
threats biden says his plan will create
millions of jobs and
some economists who have studied it
agree i
estimated that that program could create
between
roughly three and six million
new jobs in the united states permanent
jobs as long as we continued investing
at that level that's far more than the
fewer than 200 000 people who currently
work in the oil
gas and coal industries for every job
created in manufacturing or construction
there are many additional jobs created
in the economy from the spending of
those workers those are high-wage jobs
with excellent benefits
in addition to ignoring global warming
the trump administration drastically
loosened environmental regulations and
leased protected federal lands for
mining and drilling
some of what trump has done is
reversible but what you never get back
is the years that you lost
and the thing to know about climate
change is
it's the first problem we've ever come
up against with a real time limit
that is if we do not solve it soon then
we will never solve it
and we just tossed away four years that
we could have been working on solving it
there is much work to be done and the
climate clock
is ticking rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles